l'économie mondiale sévèrement touché
par l'épidémie de coronavirus après
l'europe c'est l'économie américaine la
première au monde qui inquiète
en france l'insee a tenté de chiffrer
l'impact économique du confinement et il
s'annonce historiquement élevé cette
crise présenté comme la pire depuis 1945
risque-t-elle de provoquer une nouvelle
dépression eh bien on voit cela tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
avec nous par skype confinement oblige
bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques pourquoi de
nombreux économistes parle-t-il d'une du
risque d'une dépression aujourd'hui y
compris en france
mais olivier l'économie française est en
train de s'arrêter avec le confinement
de nombreuses activités ne peuvent en
effet passé au télétravail et se faire
de manière décentralisée le risque d'une
faillite d'ailleurs se précise pour de
nombreuses pme et pas seulement nous
avons appris aujourd'hui que le
chausseur andré s'était mis en cessation
de paiement et donc ce rite va être
d'autant plus grand que la durée du
confinement va s'allonger
alors comme vous l'avez dit l'insee a
publié les premières prévisions et ces
dernières ne sont pas bonnes elles sont
d'ailleurs très probablement encore trop
optimiste il faut donc s'attendre à ce
que le coronavirus pousse l'économie
française ainsi que d'autres économies
dans le monde dans la dépression
alors jacques est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur les
prévisions de l'insee
oui tout à fait alors l'insee a fait une
première estimation de la baisse
d'activité de l'économie elle estimé car
je rappelle que ces chiffres datent
maintenant du 26 mars elle estimé à
moins de 35 % du niveau global
d'activité seulement et c'est un vrai
véritable problème
cette estimation est certainement trop
optimiste par exemple sur l'agriculture
où il ya une baisse que de 4% et bien on
va constater très vite que l'agriculture
manque de main d'oeuvre saisonnière même
chose des services marchands et non
marchands
même quand le télétravail peut être
utilisés connaissent en réalité des
baisses de production plus importante
que les chiffres qui sont estimés par
l'insee alors du coup jacques calais
vous votre estimation
avec quelques collègues nous avons fait
nos estimations en utilisant d'ailleurs
les données de l'insee
vont calculer la production hebdomadaire
de l'économie française puis nous avons
calculé cela en fonction de l'impact du
confinement
comme vous pouvez le voir la première
colonne donne le niveau de production
hebdomadaire pour 2019 la seconde
pourcentage estimé de baisse de la
production est roi coach on a été
peut-être plus sévère que l'insee et la
troisième la valeur hebdomadaire de la
production une fois la fin du conte
filmant et comment cela serait partie
t-il en fonction du nombre de semaines
de confinement est bien regardons tout
d'abord ce que nous dit l'insee alors
lindsay n'a pas calculé par semaine mais
a calculé par mois et on voit ici que
pour un mois la baisse globale sur
l'année 2020 serait de 3% la baisse
globale pour deux mois serait 2 6%
ce sont les chiffres qui sont donnés par
l'insee mais sur ce point vous vous
diverger aussi jacques oui parce que
nous avons considéré que le confinement
duré tout d'abord entre 6 et 8 semaines
et nous allons surtout considéré que le
retour à la normale ne seraient pas
automatiques ainsi que le suppose
l'insee nous avons marin gagne plus dans
nous donner ces différents aspects et
nous l'avons fait y compris pour les
données de l'insee
alors on voit là que ça pousse les
données de l'insee à lui pour cent pour
huit semaines mais que donne aux données
nous arrivons à -10%
nous avons aussi une troisième hypothèse
qui combine un petit peu l'hypothèse de
l'insee est la nôtre et qui suppose par
exemple que dans les deux premières
semaines
eh bien on pourrait avoir des niveaux de
production qui serait proche de ce que
l'insee a prévu mais que après pour la
3e 4e 5e semaine et bien l'économie se
calent ray progressivement sur notre
scénario et on voit là que l'on arrive à
une baisse de production pour l'année
2020 je le répète de 9,7 pour ça mais du
coup jacques ce sont des baisses
considérables
oui absolument olivier sont les baisses
tout à fait considérable le choc sur la
production et le pire que la france ait
connue depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
depuis 1945
l'impact sur les pme peut être
absolument
dévastateur des grandes entreprises sont
elles mieux protégés par le système de
chômage partiel qui touche désormais
quatre millions de personnes
mais si le gouvernement tarde à soutenir
les pme et les tpe qui n'ont plus de
rentrées d'argent il faut le dire
eh bien nous pourrions avoir entre eux
ça cent mille et un million de chômeurs
de plus à la fin de cette année et quel
en sera l'impact sur les finances
publiques
bonne idée il faut bien dire que
l'impact sera lourd est là aussi nous
avons utilisé les chiffres de l'insee
puis nous avons utilisé nos propres
estimations et on voit que le fardeau ça
pourrait être un déficit budgétaire
allant de - 8 % pour le calcul de six
semaines de l'insee jusqu à -11% pour
huit semaines
d'après les calculs que nous avons fait
alors que peut-il se passer
et bien bonne question
on a plusieurs à plusieurs hypothèques
ce alors trois sources de financement
ont été évoqués tout d'abord les fameux
corona bon les bons qui seraient émis
uniquement par rapport à cette épidémie
et dont on sait qu'ils ont été refusé
d'emblée par l'allemagne et par les pays
bas et puis nous avons la mobilisation
du mécanisme européen de stabilité mes
là les italiens et les français
d'ailleurs exige qu'il se fasse sans
condition ceux qui refusaient par
l'allemagne donc exit aussi cette
possibilité reste ce qu'a fait la banque
centrale européenne ce qu'on appelle le
pandémique emma jones épaule chasing
programme
et qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va en
résulter et bien tout simplement que la
banque centrale européenne va se mettre
à acheter massivement de la dette des
différents pays de la zone rouge
alors on est aujourd'hui devant une
situation qui devient de plus en plus
compliqué on voit bien que le
confinement plus il durera plus il
provoquera une dépression sévère de
l'économie et on voit aussi que de la
politique du gouvernement de sa capacité
à réagir dépendra énormément le fait que
cette dépression ne soit que transitoire
ce qu'il faut espérer ou qu'elles se
prolongent
malheureusement au delà de l'épidémie
merci beaucoup jacques pour ses
explications très éclairant 20 sur les
implications économiques de cette crise
sans précédent bon courage dans votre
confinement à très bientôt sur rt france